new at noon today a push to loosen  coveted restrictions here in clark  county  county commissioner marilyn kirkpatrick  is sending a proposal to the state's  covet 19 task force  and to governor steve sisolak it would  expand capacity limits to 50 percent for  public gatherings  and that does include live entertainment  now this plan is based on  recommendations from health officials  from across the state  amid the recent drop in covet cases and  hospitalization rates  what we'd like to do is get back to  where we were prior to the pass  so that we can start putting folks back  to work and  with the possibility of more kids going  back to school  it'll start putting the life back into  our community that  we're all looking for again this is a  proposal it would be a much needed boost  though for the local economy  she is hopeful capacity limits will be  increased by march 1st  but of course it all depends on the case  numbers so we will follow that when it's  presented